tell me his name again vanna's he's a
plague Tony he invades planets he takes
what he wants he wipes out half the
population
he said Loki the attack on New York
that's him what's her timeline
no telly he has the power and space
stones that already makes him the
strongest creature in the whole universe
if he gets his hands on all $6 Tony he
could destroy life on a scale hitherto
on dreamt on did you seriously just say
Hitler 200,000 seriously leaning on the
cauldron of the cosmos no Vanessa I'm
going to allow them if Thanos states all
six why don't we just stick this one
down the garbage disposal no can do we
swore an oath to protect the time stone
with our lives and I swore off dairy but
then Ben and Jerry's named a flavor
after me so start craving hazelnuts stop
in shock one of the early decisions we
made on infinity war we knew we wanted
to go big the storyline of infinity war
is big the cast roster and character
roster of infinity war is big the visual
effects the worlds we visit are big the
movie had to seem big and Joanne dance
said let's shoot in IMAX and the
question up to that point was okay well
which sequences is enough the entire
movie should be shot in IMAX
they're fantastic cameras the chip is
incredible that's at a resolution that
is unprecedented so I think as
filmmakers it's an amazing tool for us
the way that captures light the way that
captures color in civil war we had a
sequence that took place in an airport
and that really became a test scene for
us for a couple of reasons the first was
we've never had that many characters
interacting with each other before in
one sequence it was also a test for
those IMAX cameras to say can we utilize
the sheer enormity of this frame and the
answer quickly was yes it was the
success of that sequence with all the
cast with the IMAX cameras and with Joan
Anthony Russo directing that really gave
us the confidence to say let's even
embark on insanity war let's put more
characters in it but certainly have Joe
and Anthony directed and let's use IMAX
cameras for the whole thing
[Music]
put a smile on my face
I think if you were to look at the last
ten years as a book of Enders 3 and I've
been judge for the final chapters of
that book there are some endings there's
some new beginnings that they're one of
the great values of these movies is like
nobody's ever seen something quite like
them a level of ambition in these films
are pretty high and we needed that
equipment that could help us fulfill
that ambition
anytime you know what it's like to lose
feel so desperately that you're right
yet to fail all the same from day one on
a production when the cameras first
start rolling we think about the
audience that is anticipating the
experience that we'll be buying their
tickets early waiting online if they
have to reserving their seats sitting
that feeder waiting for the lights to go
down and we just think about one thing
and one thing only delivering on that
promise delivering on that experience
and that's the immersive experience that
IMAX gives you when you lose the rest of
the theater you don't see it all you see
is the image and allows you to be in
that world because that's what we want
that's what we want the audience to
experience is to be on that journey with
us with the characters in as full and
rich and immersive way as possible and
that's why I mixed us
[Music]
everybody its charlie happy infinity war
week so we got some new footage of Hulk
when he crash-lands in the sanctum but
also a really big heads up from Kevin
Feige and the Russos that they shot the
entire movie in IMAX cameras so even if
the first time you see the movie is just
like in a regular format I would
recommend that you try to check it out
in IMAX or Dolby vision those are my two
favorites 3d isn't quite as important
but when you hear that they specifically
designed the film with the IMAX format
in mind it just gives you like that
extra information in the frame that kind
of changes the context of some scenes if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos I'm
doing an Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
that'll be going on for the rest of the
year pretty much on a weekly basis
because we have Avengers 4 coming up all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video the really cool thing about this
whole clip is the number of Easter eggs
that they work into this they said that
there was a lot of improvisation on sets
so I wonder what else didn't make it
into the final version of this scene but
you have Bruce Banner playing the part
of Silver Surfer from comic book
Infinity Gauntlet crashing through the
sanctum and warning dr. strange that
Thanos is coming now Iron Man wasn't
there in the comic book version of this
scene just because he was still kind of
a b-list character during the 90s it was
until Robert Downey jr. came on and sort
of reinvigorated interest in the
character that he became a really big
deal in the comics but you can kind of
see how they use these character
pairings to balance the humor and the
drama because this is meant to be a
really serious scene Hulk is telling
them
vanna's already has two of the Infinity
stones the power and the space stone
he's already the most powerful creature
in the entire universe
so he leans on the cauldron of the
cosmos and just starts stretching his
legs like he's warming up for a bite I
don't think he realizes that Thanos his
ship is about to come into orbit because
you know after this scene they all go
outside and they see all this
destruction he doesn't know that that's
coming him reacting to the cloak of
levitation is hilarious because remember
he's a scientist his entire life has
been dedicated to that field of study so
the idea that magic exists is a small
leap for him I mean he probably gets on
board pretty quickly but him just
casually dismissed all these powerful
magical artifacts just seems so funny
can we throw it down the trash no you
cannot destroy in infinities
stone and it turns out that there's a
flavor of ben and jerry's made after
tony stark stark raving hazelnuts which
dr. strange has tried if you're not a
big comic book reader before secret wars
happened a couple years ago there was an
event called time runs out where the
beyonders basically said that we're
gonna destroy the multiverse because
we're done with reality this is an
experiment of ours that we don't care
about anymore the avengers on the main
version of earth the six one-sixth
universe realized what's going on
so the illuminati formed the Infinity
Gauntlet again because they each possess
one of the Infinity stones Captain
America uses it to stop one of the other
realities from destroying their earth
but in the process of doing so cracks
one of the Infinity stones so as of
right now there's only a couple ways to
destroy Infinity stones one you could
use the power of the beyonders which
doesn't exist in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe or you can use Infinity stones
in the gauntlet from another reality so
something of equal or greater power is
just that we haven't seen anything of
greater power than the Infinity Gauntlet
because that's the whole MacGuffin of
these next two Avengers films the
Infinity stones forming the gauntlet
changing reality there been a lot of
questions about them introducing cosmic
concepts as of me posting this video I
haven't seen the movie yet so I can't
tell you what other concepts that they
introduced during the movie but we can
talk about that after everyone has a
chance to see it next week so here's
what the infinity war week schedule is
going to be Monday I'm allowed to post
like a very brief non spoilery reaction
to the film Tuesday I'm allowed to post
my full non spoilery review still no
spoilers then after that I'm cleared to
do whatever but I won't be posting my
spoiler review till Friday Easter eggs
post credit scene all that kind of stuff
won't post till the end of next week
after I know that everybody's seen the
movie so when I post those videos next
week it should be pretty evident from
the video title what it's about whether
or not it's a spoiler like I will say
spoiler review in the title when I post
my spoiler review so no worries there
shouldn't be any confusion about what
videos are non-spoilery and what videos
are spoilery there is a special take a
giveaway that I'm doing that I started
in my Deadpool video I'll link that at
the end of this so you guys can learn
about that if you don't know what's
going on but I'll name the winner for
that when I post my Westworld
episode 1 video
later tonight but click here for that
Deadpool video and learn about that
infinity war ticket giveaway and click
here to get ready for West world tonight
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome we'll see you guys tonight
[Music]